four or five years ago you would I would
show up to campuses I was physically
attacked at one campus you'd have major
protests you'd have people yelling at
you in the room and I've noticed that in
the last few years and especially after
covid more people are showing up the
audiences are bigger than ever but there
aren't so many attacks there aren't so
many protests one reason for that is the
Liberals realized that we were making
them look extremely foolish on on air
and so they stopped showing up but two I
think there has been an actual sea
change and I think that that is what you
are seeing reflected in the polls right
now yeah what you were seeing with
Suburban moms and what you're seeing and
people all around the country that is
actually being reflected on the college
campuses too and I think they're
realizing something has gone seriously
wrong here something is broken even
though Joe Biden is trying to buy off
all their votes and give student loans
and just give away all of our taxpayer
money I don't think it's really working
I think you were seeing campuses come
back to normal